go live
okay people just joining this live
stream we
are about to do a design review for
geometry and graphics
for the upcoming version of orphan
language 12.3
so looks like we have all kinds of
interesting things
coming here all right
let's uh let's look at
first of all region dilation so where
should i look at that
just the source docutools yeah
okay
um my first question is how does this
relate to dilation and erosion
at the image processing level it's the
same thing
then why has got a different function
sorry
why then why is it a different function
because that one is specialized to
pixel-oriented geometry
okay you're gonna have to sell me on
that
okay well we can rename it to minkowski
some
oh i i don't think that's okay let's
take a look at this
okay okay so how am i supposed to know
okay so if i were to do this
okay so the region dilation
so i don't understand why it doesn't
self visualize
here to begin with so if i do that
what's taking why is it taking so long
oh that's cool
okay so there's no sense
in which wow
didn't it have to i mean does it always
have to do that internally even when
it's just going to generate a region
visualization at the end yes
wow this is i mean
it's magnificent but it's awfully slow
what would happen if it was a mesh
it would be fast so so if for example if
i take this
and i turn that into i say um
no they both need to be measures i
understand but you say
you say um it won't work at this time
at the performance you are still working
on it okay but
but i'm just trying to understand
because i'm trying to understand the
analogy with
with dilation and erosion so if i take
discretized graphics there
if i were to take discretized graphics
of the triangle
discretized graphics of the disk
okay then what do i have here then those
are these are self
visualizing things so if i say region
dilation of those
i will get presumably a self-visualizing
oh
boy no it is because right we have like
this which doesn't auto visualize right
so if you return disk
you'll be this oh wait wait sorry sorry
sorry i did this
okay so why didn't this auto visualize
so wait a minute we've got two
completely different things coming out
here
this okay so this is this is the analog
of that implicit region is that polygon
region there
and if i now say graphics of that
or region yeah i understand then i will
get that
okay so let me understand what happens
if i now say dilation of
this thing here if i said dilation of
this rather than region dilation what
would happen
dilation take an image i guess you will
complain i know but i'm asking why is
that why why isn't it
the same function
why isn't the same function that can
take regions or images here
well at least for my understanding
dilation is for image so essentially i i
know what you think
i i know that you think that did you did
you watching
further yeah go ahead white it's working
on z2
right essentially the domain image are
essentially lattices
why this is on the occlusion space on
our end
is it shoddy here no
we can get her here okay so dilation
here has an image and a kernel
yeah let's get shoddy please
and what's the difference so now you
have instead of an image in a kernel you
have a
a region and an r well r
is just a convenience for a disk of
radius r okay so that's the second
argument here
but except that it's a range r square
here
exactly because
come on come on look why is it a square
here and a disc here
because at least from my perspective one
case is you know
you know there is different dilation in
different spaces this is a special case
of
the equilibrium case for geometry
this is also has the interpretation a
distance r from the region
right okay and in geometry is equivalent
to the sum
of the way john as well as the minkowski
sum wherein
you know in dilation and image have a
different interpretation
even though the concept in general is
the same
makes me wonder if we should start
pushing image dilation as the name for
dilation here
so this is a kernel with structuring
structuring i want
cur which is similar to cur is just
their way you know because it's sort of
this at first approximation this works
for black and white images so they
basically work
it's sort of an image implementation of
regions very understanding
i understand what it is occur is a way
to give
sort of a micro region exactly
exactly it's it's a it's your region too
which is which is
you know you're basically convolving
region two onto region one
no correct you're adding them you're not
convolving anything well
you you're you're taking a kernel and
you're into whatever you
you're smearing it out by taking this as
like a greens function
of this thing and you're applying you're
integrating at every point
you're taking that kernel right you're
adding it on yeah
you're not integrating you're adding it
but when you write it
in the discrete sense why the
integration is adding
yes but you're going around the boundary
this is a look at the definition just
below there the set
a plus b
i understand okay that's the definition
so it's symmetric in reg one and reg two
it is is this symmetric an image incur
no why not um
i think that they were thinking of it as
kind of like
a a um
a finessing operation which
i'm saying you have an image that's
dirty in some ways and now you want to
dilate it you know i understand okay so
listen listen
the design of this song but this has on
its own
very important use cases just the sum of
two regions
i i understand this seems like a
perfectly fine design on its own
i don't understand how it relates to
this we're going to need shadi for that
discussion she's not available right now
so we're going to come back to this okay
so who is who is
so yes well you're the one doing notes
here so this is this we need to come
back to
in a subsequent meeting now the uv
mechanism here
where those are the sort of the the
scaling factors for reg one and reg two
why do you put those at the end like
that why are they not sort of associated
with reg one and reg two
how would you wanna do that if they were
associated
i don't know arrows or lists or
something
i mean my only point is that that
uh i mean so there is a you know by the
way if you have sort of one comma minus
one
some people call that the minkowski
difference
but there is another definition of
different difference too which is the
erosion difference
which is not the same as that okay but
both are useful
and often frequently so i see so you're
saying i i guess i remember from
many many years ago that the whole yeah
this place that did environmental
something or other that defined all
these operators they had a whole
anyway earlier much processing stuff
sure okay there so so that's a reason to
put those two together that you are
thinking of this as a modified dilation
operator
where the operator specification is the
uv
pair right so that's a reason to assert
to have that as a pair rather than have
it associated directly with reg one and
reg two
yeah okay i'm sold on that
and the same goes for region erosion
i agree is that but does that what
you've done with region erosion
yes
okay i mean i'm sold on that that's fine
okay let's take a look at these
well
i mean i will say that as a as a you
know increasingly serious user of this
geometry
and region stuff
my many aspects of it are very nice
my major complaint is all of this
oh you needed to discretize that region
oh it was the wrong kind of mesh
you know we are aware i mean so
is that something you can fix
we're steadily fixing it okay that's
fine
um and so we're we're aware all right
okay good because i mean i think it's
just a question of things eating the
right
kinds of food so to speak yes
okay so this is this is your go-to
version if you write
programs that use geometric regions you
want to use canonicalized regions
canonicalized region to not have to deal
with so many
um cases in your code
well it doesn't help me if i if i'm
pattern matching right or does it or do
i just say
underscore point and then i lit to
localize canonicalized origin deal with
it
well you could yes
but the thing is that you know like like
an example do you treat
uh do you have no no i understand the
issue i mean i understand that there's
plenty of these special cases
mainly many many why are you not
canonicalizing a rectangle to a polygon
or couldn't wouldn't you let people do
that
well that's a more a conversation like
we have canon
um canonicalized polygon we should take
a rectangle and we write it as a polygon
why is it called sorry why is it called
canico's region not region canonicalized
because it well i see you've got a
canonicalized family with kanakos
polygon and things like that
right okay fine that's what comes out of
them
okay all right okay fine oh i see it yes
that makes sense
um okay well let's look at region
convert
over time there will be more forms
um here
okay but if i want to solve a pde or
something
it should be able to take any of these
things as food right
yes okay the solvers that we provide
they eat anything if you have to program
your own solver
you want to be able to get access to
this well
let's be realistic if i take this and i
say
but you wrote your own solver so you're
the one dealing with it so to speak
okay well okay but what i'm saying is if
i take this
and i say something like okay so if i
say something like area
boom it'll work okay now let's say i say
something like
plot sine x y
uh x y element of that thing
dot 3d
magnificent okay
now what if i wanted to take that region
and i want to make
how do i make a mesh from that region or
do i need to make a mash
sometimes discretize region
how do i make a graph yeah okay so let's
say i say discretize region
now why am i saying okay discretized
region of that thing
okay
as opposed to what would happen if i
took that percent nine and i said
discretized graphics of that
discretized graphics mission has not
been fully fulfilled
yeah so it works in that case well it is
graphics
but the long-term goal for discretized
graphics is much more ambitious
we think of graphics as a giant
unstructured database
a super primitives can you fish things
out of that can you search basically in
that soup
that was part of the original intent for
discretized graphics that we will
fulfill eventually what do you mean by
such
how search how pick out the red parts
discretizer get me only the red parts
exclude this
why is that the function discretized
graphics why is discretized graphics
relevant to that operation
because graphics itself is a container
of a whole world of unstructured things
so i understand but why does that
function i mean
why isn't there a function called filter
graphics or something
pick out the red parts and then
discretize graphics is a separate thing
i didn't understand why discretized
graphics is the one that picks out the
red bits
um question
doesn't seem right it's a possibility
just this has to still be well-formed
graphics that comes out so no no i
understand that i i'm saying that i
think i think it's an interesting idea
to have something that is capable of
treating graphics
you know doing graphics cases for
example
or something but you can just do cases
on graphics but maybe you do it with
other criteria
we have shoddy here the issue that we're
we're addressing is these guys have
region dilation and
i am complaining about its failure to
to conform to what dilation does
i also have never liked dilation as a
name
i mean i always thought it should be
image dilation
the operation is really the same is is
there
yeah but but they're struggling what
about opening is there a region opening
no what does it mean why isn't there
well
we can add one eventually but i mean it
would mean something
but they would have to have use cases no
no i understand that but i'm just
checking
is there a generalization of the concept
of opening yes there is
because it's defined in terms of those
other operations
okay so the thing that i'm pushing is
why is there a separate function called
region dilation
that is different from i mean is there
there is a is there a region plus
no is this is sort of region plus
regeneration is basically region plus
but there's no meaning to region
but there's a region difference which is
a different thing
right region difference is complex is
complement
basically yes and
unfortunately yes it's it's named region
difference because
many people have named it difference i
mean in lots of cat systems it's the
difference of regions
right okay but the thing that i'm
pushing
is the
slight you know the bizarre differences
between region dilation and dilation
like for example the different choice of
a disk versus a square i understand why
you're doing it
range r square
i mean an arbitrary kernel can be
specified as well which would be
equivalent to
regen one region two specification the
two arc form of regen dilation
i don't know what's the three arc form
there some
linear combination you can have you can
have a negative
you can have region a minus region too
but you could also support for dilation
i would like to suggest something that i
again i mean dilation opening closing
they've always bothered me
they're really not the right names i
mean
well okay you're gonna argue that they
also work on arrays
do they also work on arrays yes they do
they do
but how do they work on arrays with
which are not just zero one arrays
because like you're either in a region
or you're not in region you're either
isn't this it it works as a
max operation or mean operation for
erosion
same way as uh dilation and erosion work
on grayscale images
all right i'm getting sold here
these are pages that hasn't been
overhauled so these are the old style
documentation that you guys did in image
processing
they will be upgraded to modern yeah i
mean this is a very nice picture
um
uh all right fine i'm sold
i do think you should harmonize things
like putting in the uv arguments to
dilation
not a high priority but something good
now what about
padding option that's irrelevant here
right
yes
okay i am reluctantly sold okay
i have no objections should we move on
yep um here is a cool application
for region dilation yeah if you want to
solve a planning problem like a robot
motion of planning
so yeah the question is can you move
this robot through
the piano problem yes
what you want to do is to figure out
whether when you
when you get it yeah whether when the
piano is moving around whether it hits
whether it can can make it right and
there's a whole slew of others called
the
packing and cutting problems i wonder
whether there's packaging that we should
provide
top-level functions that we should
provide that are more obviously related
to that
no no we will but we're working on i'm
work not
so it's coming that's cool that's very
cool
all right let's go on
so i have no objection i mean region
converts and all those things those seem
fine to me
good
oh boy photo realistic uh materials
okay yeah so sander is saying on our
live stream
he's looking forward to region dilation
region erosion good
he's asking will they be fast on mesh
regions
not yet they will be soonish
but not yet okay
all right so this is a graphics
directive right
is that correct yes
it goes along with shading yeah so
that's a shading like in the shading
family
so it's a but shading itself and by the
way i'm not sure
shoddy needs to um
all right i can drop off is that correct
i mean is there anything else for shoddy
here
no okay great thank you see ya
oh wow i'm so out of date
okay so so
yep that's a really okay
so this is it's like why isn't shading
pointing to like specularity
okay so that's what this is like
material shading is kind of like
specularity and things correct
it's a much deeper model so here's
what's happened it's
there's a consortium that got initiated
2012
between pixar disney
autodesk and others to provide for a
model where you can design materials
and hand them off between different
tools yeah i understand
so it's a full modeling language for
real time but realistic shading
i get it but it's much more than
specularity i i understand that i
understand that but
as is always the case we've got to plug
it into other things we're doing
absolutely right so you know presumably
specularity so if i give a pewter
something or other and then i
and and i choose to increase the
specularity that would still work or are
we deprecating specularity
no that still works okay
i mean i think specularity is useful
do you agree or do you think it's no
it's useful
okay all right so let's take a look at
this
does this support entities for these
things
yes so most of them will
as well yeah well at this time it
doesn't fully support entities forecasts
you know we are discussing we said we
agreed that we would right
yes but not for this common release i
mean we need to
actually gather the data and build it
yes that's in the plan
i mean our material properties don't
store the properties that we need for
these models
obviously right yet yet
okay so we've been in discussion with
with um
with that michael yeah
uh so so yeah so
how okay let me understand something so
if i what is there a file
extension for one of these material
property files or something
yes and so then they can come in
in xml and so not for now but we will
eventually have an import
format for that okay i mean you can also
then presumably you can say material
shading of file blah blah blah
probably that's not a bad idea but
that's a
graphic directive why do we want to
import a file
well because we need to because it
because it's something you're telling me
there can be an external file
that this is so well we'll keep that
later i mean there was the
i mean so when we'll get to the you know
the shedding language
we plan to extend is where that will
actually appear where you can actually
import a a shader specification from
another software maya and such
but you will not by default okay i think
that's wrong i think what should happen
is the thing should okay so here's a
couple of comments
what is the what is the output blob from
this if i just say material shading of
iron does it show up as a blob or does
it just show up as a
as a not evaluated thing
so as soon as it's a blob you could be
importing from a file at that point
that's nice that's nice
quite nice very nice actually boy
photorealistic
you know things like this we've been
waiting for that for people started
asking us about that in 1988.
and there's beethoven or something and
this is this is
increasingly i mean what what can be
done in real time is
as kind of i mean it's still approximate
in some sense but they're pretty damn
good
yeah and you can do real-time rotation
of this
yeah and and how does this relate to our
light sources is this using this is
okay you fake the light sources here so
if i were to take
so we're going to add a new string we
need to add a new string value
that's i mean you can use the default
lightest no problem
okay so this is a three-point light
source
it's not going to look as good as
opposed to what is this one
a three-point light source no this one
here this one this one
the three-point light source it's just
three directional lights
okay but this is all it's called
three-point lighting this is
how you do interviews like if you see on
the tv okay i understand what you're
saying yes i understand that
standardized as opposed to our default
lighting
which is colored as colors and so on
which would definitely not work for
humans on in interviews
although it would be amusing right i
mean they will look like a little
purplish
but that i mean it might be it might be
amusing
you might get used to purplish looking
people yeah purple people
as opposed to eaters right um okay
so
you're saying that for the
photorealistic case you would want to
have lighting arrow
what well actually
it would be good we need to come up with
a name for that a string name for that
but it's basically a three-point light
you know just as well what's confusing
about that is that
i mean i would think something like
studio
will be better as you know
the studio lighting can be flat you know
most tv you know okay well that but but
then i i think it's too confusing the
reason i think it's confusing is that
our default lighting
is three-point lighting that's the
problem it hasn't
been four points i thought it was three
but
but um
or maybe it's needs well okay let's
let's see if we can come up with a
better name though
but they usually laugh um okay
well i think but i think it'd be good to
name it
not i think it'd be good to have curated
string names for things like three-point
lighting and whatever
other just as you know when we have
video fades we'll have names for the
you know the ken burns fade or whatever
it is right
um the um you know similarly we should
have industry
names for these things but i think we
also should have common names for them
yeah i mean i mean if you have a
brilliant idea right now
well i i don't know i mean i'm kind of
thinking what you use this for is
photorealistic rendering in some sense
or material rendering or something or or
you know
lighting arrow realism material
i don't know something because that's
the case that you want it for right
you're gonna is some museum
i don't know if it is museum lighting
but and that isn't quite right either
it's too whimsical i mean we want
something where because people who are
doing photorealistic stuff
want their you know they're going to do
this all the time
i mean this is more like lighting a
physical object
as opposed to you know lighting arrow
physical that doesn't sound right either
we need another name i don't know what
it should be
um but it's something like physical or
something you know because
we'll we'll come up with something okay
okay all right let's take a look
if you have a brilliant idea just email
i mean okay
okay okay this is nice though okay so
then
these things here so that standard
doesn't come with actual design material
so these are materials that we've
uh curated okay all right so are we
going to have
so i mean you know as we know for the
the color uh palettes
you know i really want to see those in a
repository
and you know a lightweight repository
and these presumably the same type of
thing
they should be in a lightweight
repository of materials
do you agree yeah we need something when
if we start to get lots of material if
we start to build lots of material
we need another mechanism that's right
so what i think it should be is just
like the mechanism for neural nets which
is but the thing is that you
how the heck do you find them well
that's the whole point that's the whole
point roger
that's the i don't think people find
them i mean maybe they find them on a
web or something but
that's exactly where they find that okay
roger but that's not what this is
what you're going to be in that's that
two-step wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
wait a minute first of all we're
assuming everybody is connected to the
web
obviously okay so what has happened with
net model which i consider to be very
successful
is that you go you know the workflow is
you want a neural net okay you can
either know what it is as
or you can just say let me go to the
neural net repository
browse for my neural net you know
whatever it is things like this
and then i just get it there it is net
model of the thing
and you know and now i can get that
network right
and i think that's the right model i
think it's the right model for color
palettes i think it's the right model
for these materials
so in other words what this really means
when you say
material shading of silver what that
really means is that in the material
repository
there is a page that looks like you know
that is about that material
similarly with a color palette instead
of it just being some random name
and instead of you finding it in you
know in palettes here
you're you're you know you're finding it
in a
and then it is our responsibility to
have a meaningful
browse page like this which depending on
how many materials there are how many
pallets there
are we change what that looks like
yeah so i think that's the place to go
now in terms of in-product browsing
that is something that we need to work
on and
and yes well this is something for some
reason it's but dropped off
of the agenda but you know pioneered by
system modeler
with its in-product browser for examples
we need to have an in-product browser
for repositories
okay not making sense yes um
and uh the um
yeah so that's the place to go with
these i think and i think the thing to
do is to start off with this kind of
the the the el chipo you know we'll just
provide a few of these
here that are documented right here on
this page
and then expect to go to something which
is a lightweight repository makes sense
too it does make sense i mean we were
yeah okay
so we also thought that the the water
yeah entity we thought was another way
to get to it
okay what i think is the case is that
you're never going to design you know in
here you're going to have
random tartans and all kinds of random
weird stuff right
you're going to have all kinds of random
weird flaky things and so on you know
those are never going to be entities of
that type
i think i think just like these things
are not entities
these are sort of entities are things
that sort of exist in the real world
so for example chemical elements
absolutely they're entities
uh edmund is asking on our live stream
would element entities get a material
shading property they absolutely should
and we should be able to do that
of course to be realistic that's
complicated because
let's say you have an element let's say
carbon right
as well you're not just dealing with an
element there you're dealing with
diamond graphite etc
but you're even dealing with you know
what is the cleavage plane
that you're using etc etc etc and my
guess is
that for the immediate future it will be
much more relevant to have
named sort of repository like
uh um uh you know materials
rather than i mean you know we may be
able to base them like sulfur for
example you know what what should sulfur
look like
it depends on the preparation yeah but i
think in real life you you sort of uh
i mean yes it might be educational and
so on to get
the various kinds of medals or and so on
directly
but in real life if you think of of that
this is portraying something
you want kind of like a dirty copper you
want of course you do right which is
oxidized
exactly which is why i'm saying don't go
for entities go for a repository
yeah because the repository is much more
free i mean a repository
you put whatever you want in it it
doesn't have to be something that
sort of relates to the world and has all
the you know the same properties and so
on
it's the right thing i mean linking some
entities to this is a good thing
but i would only go so far with that i
mean i would as a courtesy
i would link some entities there but
you're never going to get all the
different forms of iron
you know you'll have some generic iron
that comes from that
makes sense i mean yeah you can have all
kinds of weird things i mean you could
have
you know mars right we now know that
mars you know
looks like i i just did our i used our
um
identifier to say that that's that
geolocation image identifier the one
that says where
where a photograph is according to it
the the perseverance rover is somewhere
in in egypt so you could start a
conspiracy theory from that
oh yeah great
the other thing is that there is a
monograph coming uh that describes this
underlying shading model so it's easier
to then design
more okay but i think this is wonderful
so let me ask a question so these things
are fundamentally okay there's an
association
um and are these values
kind of constant values they're just
those are just colors
right in the next revision we would like
to extend this to be varying things
and they're going to vary by providing a
texture
well it's actually already documented
downstairs so the value can be a color a
texture
or a texture plus a multiplier factor
i see well that's another reason you do
not want to go for entities i i thought
you're gonna have tartans and you are
what's tartans oh i just you know these
these scottish
you know iconic whatever i mean just oh
these crisscross patterns
i see which have nothing to do with the
material you know
a crisscross on copper isn't isn't
really um
okay what is this normal what does that
mean what does normal mean
is there oh that's not to the surface
normal vector but why is this why is the
value point eight
why is it wasn't a normal vector i don't
understand that
right so there is the normal vector you
you can give usually they give it as a
texture
or you can we can also take a numerical
value to kind of amplify it
so that's a multiplier of the of of the
natural normal vector
i don't understand why this is called
normal it should probably be normal
weight or something
yeah this just doesn't seem right normal
multiplier or something like that
it's it's presumably it's in the shading
equation presumably
well is it is essential to normal vector
so we could have written but it's not a
vector
point vector no no hold on hold on
it's a normal vector but for
convenience we can also take a texture
which also encapsulate that normal
vector
in the rgb color it's what usually
people do yeah but you're interested
in correct but you see also in
illustration there is a second argument
comma
s sure we can fix the illustration but
there is also a fraction
effect to amplify an effect right you
can have a texture and you want to
amplify the effect
right is that illustration team added
there maybe we need to adjust the
illustration but it doesn't mean that
the spec is wrong
okay what does the value for normal what
what it's supposed to be
so by default the normal is a vector in
this case a
three value vector right okay okay
but it is then it should be maybe we
should call it normal vector
i think so i think so
and i don't understand this i mean
documentation wise this should surely
say normal vector arrow
vec or something metallic arrow
i mean a list of vectors or something so
we're not just
you know i think these should say what
their what their right hand side is
well we we put it below we say the value
because some the value can be a color
it can be a texture it can be a list of
colors
but where's the colors palm i oh okay
possible colors by my
are this fraction of the color
contribution to the final color
i do not understand that so in in some
case you can
you know you can make it red but you
can't we want it
coffee speaking like dilute that that
way in the contribution at the end so
you can make you know see
you know half of that color will apply
at the end which giving you know a nice
effect
it's more a convenience of flexibility
parameter
i think i need to understand a little
bit better um
and uh let's see
uh jari is asking do these materials
work well with exports
to realistic renderers um
what's the answer to that in other words
can you i
i mean we're gonna have a pretty good
renderer here but if you wanted to have
really fancy ray tracing type stuff can
you export this
presumably the answer is yes because
this is coming from some standard
rendering format
we don't yet yes we don't yet support
those file formats so
probably some of the file formats step
and search as we introduce them in the
future we definitely
support those this directive right
okay so by the way can we have
transparent objects as well
here does this support that these are
all
not just surface properties not yet at
this release probably in the next
release will work on the transparency so
the problem is like subsurface
scattering yeah i understand
okay so it's it's it's not beyond the
scope it's just more work to get it
right
so is there going to be fur and things
as well
i don't know about yeah there is the
valve velvet there which is yeah velvet
is a little bit like that
can you go full fur so to speak and make
them hairy and so on and
because that that involves a bunch of
diffusion level you know
diffraction level you know light
scattering and so on
possible in the future okay all right
fine but this is this is impressive
enough as it is
it's very nice and and i guess
it's good to have some of these yeah
known iron bronze fair enough i mean
these are
look these are cartoon ions and bronzers
they're not necessarily
what a real you know iron heated to such
and such a temperature glowing
whatever you know red hot iron by the
way
you should have those that will be a
cool one red hot
you know materials and things why not
um uh
just a suggestion for for how to get
something sort of spectacular
make sense sure you can have it glowing
right
yeah everything is a model so you can
you know you can
you can build up a model well i
understand it's a question of where the
model can go because
subsurface scattering is not where it
can go
um yes there's the mission color so you
can actually do that at this stage
right
um
uh nick was asking about
whether procedural material capture
oh this is this is
okay right this is this is essentially a
graph
that the thing nick was pointing to is
essentially a graph
for procedural generation and and
presumably that goes beyond the standard
but the standard will already get us a
fair distance
i mean their model is a dag yeah
so this is the one that nick was
pointing to
photographs into production grade
procedural material models that's
interesting
that's an interesting thing to do so
that's a machine learning story
going from a photograph to material
properties that does seem like a
worthwhile thing
if nothing else that should be a you
know some kind of internish project
seems like a good idea all right let me
add that
jezebel if you could yeah i know did it
yep okay all right fine you can send it
back to me and i'll add it to the list
um okay
we're going to run out of time here but
i just want to do a quick preview of
what we're going to see this is really
cool by the way guys very nice
um should we look
i mean i'd like to do one
careful look at the names of these
things um
are these names part of the standard or
are they your version of those names
guys i mean it's pretty much our version
of the names but
most of them i mean base color emission
color are kind of standard names
so
if you pretty much get any sulfur which
does that you will see base
color you know mission color and such we
see metallic offness
by the way um
sandra is asking for a specific thing
for that which i think is a little bit
of a of an ask but i think we we should
be able to get
here in that i should be able to say
gold right
yeah i see so with default
and another suggestion that that sander
or somebody was making on our live
stream um
is if we see for lighting our automatic
if we see a plot style that has material
shading why not change the lighting
seems not a totally silly suggestion i
agree
because this isn't looking very good
here no
what what would be the correct lighting
here
well are you trying neutral to begin
with at least be better
yeah it's not great well so okay fine so
we should just change the default in the
case where
where there's material shading because
there's got in a plot 3d at least
i i suspect whenever there's material
shading it will not look good unless you
have these
unless you have the fancy lighting
that doesn't look particularly good
either is that because basically
um i mean is that because these kinds of
surfaces basically just don't look very
good we're not as humans we're not very
used to seeing these things
and they just don't look very good i
mean what
explain that to me do you understand
what i'm asking
because this is the issue that we had
back 30 years ago when we were
considering doing photorealistic
rendering
you know for all kinds of mathematical
type things is it just didn't look very
good
can you add plot point goes to maybe 80
let's increase the number of plot points
it's okay but i mean you know frankly
i'd be happy with this just being yellow
right
i mean you know honestly i don't think
that's any i don't i don't get anything
for it being
the gold material here no i don't think
that that's the big use case i think
that there are two other
you know classes of of important use
cases
so one is when you model real world
things
sure so solid modeling for instance
and um anatomy is another one where i
think it might be useful
yes and also 3d printing
uh you know pre-visualization those
kinds of things
right can i put something sorry can i
put one of your complicated fancy ones
in here
how do i get that one i think there's
probably rasterized in there
no no i understand that but i'm asking
how do i is there one down there that
you can just pick up
charles is there one in the examples um
so you mean what the model the defense
says
that you use this example or
just any anything a little bit you know
we could use any not can we
no no i i don't mean not i meant i meant
i i can
i can do a knot i'm what i was asking
for was something
a more complicated material property
with more complicated roughness or
something like that
let's let's try velvet
yeah this isn't really doing it for me i
mean so what it's basically i you know
this just looks green
now on the other hand okay this is
actually very interesting visual
perception issue
so the claim would be if i were to do
um a not how do i do that if i do not
data
of let's say 4 2
oops five two
okay there's a knot so now how do i get
that
how do i how do i um show that in the in
the um with those material properties
oh it's um but you can do image data to
get the graphic and then you wrap it
around traffic well
let's see doesn't not data support uh
not as far as i know we don't add any
styling or such
we should probably support that
particularly for this case
okay so now what do you want to do here
so now i just say graphics 3d
of let's say material shading velvet
of that and that's going to be default
lighting
okay that's more interesting honestly
it's better than these surfaces i mean
that's more usefully
you know whatever yeah um
i think us humans are just wired to not
care you know
if you give us a non non-real world
thing and you try and cover it with real
world stuff it doesn't work very well
right but i think we are getting
increasingly
you know more use cases in the system i
think solid modeling geometry printing
and so on are examples
of that well yeah and just presentation
of of things like this i mean
i'd like to see some hypographs in in
velvet for example
right somebody's been pointing out um uh
yeah that would work the um physics of
the the rule for the universe should be
published in gold so it can be called
the golden rule
um yes needs physics simulation to make
it more realistic
that is coming that is coming
um okay we should we we need to wrap up
here
um so you've covered everything
the rest is relatively small
really i think we'll need another hour
okay
um fine this is very good
and we'll do we'll scatter that no
problem um
oh the switch from the gpu
is this being done on the gpu is
being landed on the gpu yes yeah i would
think so
otherwise it wouldn't be able to rotate
in real time
right very nice and i mean what about
some textures here that are a little bit
more
you know just what are you planning in
terms of the texture repository
the um the material repository in terms
of what type of things by the way
are you sure it should be called yeah i
guess it's called materials even though
the material might have a pattern in it
did you see what i'm saying there i mean
this is this is what
what these things are these assets
you know but i think you know fabric
should be
i mean i think you should plan something
where
you know there are obvious kinds of um
of textures that people might want
i'm trying to think of what types of
textures there might be
i don't think you need an asteroid not a
not shaped asteroid
not shaped uh maybe we need to do
like like these other companies that
they have job titles which are basically
material designers
um those are most of the people we see
right
well i mean i think we just need to find
out are there is there an analog of the
thingiverse for materials
yes there are several repositories of
material or
pretty much texture that they call them
so we need to
incorporate the ones that are
interesting yes
um all right i need to provide an
interface to them
what's that or provide an interface
yes yes yes well yes but look i think
it's much more useful if we curate them
and so people know what to expect and so
they have reasonable names
and you can you know show them on a on a
browsing page etc etc
anyway terrific stuff i gotta run
to be continued um thank you
see you later oh actually there's a
comment from monk
which is worth reading about light
sources and and how to position light
sources
um but i have to run